how to attract clients in real estate I
got a great question from one of my
newsletter readers love you guys
Harrison who wrote in to say hi Evan
please how can i track client and real
estate marketing kind regards and thanks
here's the thing ok real estate is one
of the most competitive businesses to
get into if you're a real estate agent
it's so hard to send out because you're
all selling the exact same product
there's tons of people out there and
you're all selling the same thing you're
being crunched down by online resources
by agents who would just sell on like 1%
commisioner or flat fee so how do you
stand out the way to do it this is
really important the way to do it is to
make it personal and combine your
passions it's funny all the real estate
agents that I know nobody does a good
job with this real estate agents are so
happy to put their face on business
cards and put their face on signs and
put their face all over their website
and yet nobody tells their story who are
you people need to know who you are what
you stand for why are you interested in
real estate
tell me your story making me feel
something besides just looking at your
face why are people gonna refer you why
are people gonna work with you because
they'd like you they know you they trust
you people will watch something here's a
good example I'll use me people come up
to me on the street or they come up to
me at conferences they write to me on
email they feel like they know me they
ask me about how this thing was that
happened in my life like I don't even
know who this person is but they feel
like they know me and that's what the
that's the relationship you need to
create with people you want people to
feel like they know who you are they
know your passions they know what gets
you excited they know why you started in
the real estate business who talks about
that nobody that's how you stand out on
top of that I'd combine the passion
because real estate alone isn't enough
find something else that you love it
could be from your personal life
something else that you love and combine
those passions together that's where you
gonna have a lot of success a great
example is not in real estate but from a
financial services perspective so a
buddy of Mines name is Steve he he's a
financial adviser infantilizes are the
same as real estate agents same in that
you have tons of competition you're all
selling the same product so how do you
stand out it's gonna be through service
so with him we spoke about it and and he
loves hockey that's his other passion he
loves financial planning and he loves
hockey good old Canadian and so how do
you say how to use hockey right like
he's the kind of guy who will watch the
the highlights on TV and watch the same
goal scored ten times and not get bored
of it he just loves it it's part of what
he loves and that's important and so how
do I combine hockey with financial
advisory services and what he did was he
started working with NHL players with
hockey players as clients and now he is
the guy who a lot of NHL stars go to for
financial advice it's a dream goal of
every financial advisor to work with the
high net worth clients right it's a
dream of every real estate agent to sell
the multi-million dollar homes not the
$300,000 ones and here's how we did it
he combined this passion and the hockey
players love working with him because
they love hockey too they have a common
interest so you have to find out who it
is who's in your target market who loves
what you do who understands your story
and says this guy I love this guy
I believe in the same thing he does so
find another cause that's close to your
heart and this isn't a marketing thing
it's not just I'm gonna I'm gonna join
this church group or I'm gonna join this
this charity because it's gonna help my
business Steve didn't go off watching
all those hockey clips because it's
gonna help his
he did because that's what he loved that
was a deep passion of his so you have to
find out what that is for you
what's another passion of yours and how
can you bring it into real estate and
start attracting other clients who need
to buy a home which is gonna be
everybody at some point but they also
have that other shared passion of yours
what is it when you do that when you
combine your passions and you tell your
story in the way that makes me feel
something towards you and I feel like
you're a genuine person who I can relate
to then they're gonna hire you and
they're going to talk about you I'm
gonna spread the word about you and your
business will explode that's how you
attract clients like crazy in the real
estate business believe those you
watching like the video give it a thumbs
up below and let me know what you think
leave a comment below the comments
always make my day I love starting my
day eating my lentils and reading your
comments you have a question for me
leave it below and you can click on my
face to subscribe to the channel thank
you so much and I'll see you soon